WK + z b dutch station pilot to
Bombardier
there's nothing but clouds out there I
cannot see pilot to Bombardier
what is my ship gonna come in when is my
ship gonna come in uncle Joey is here
[__] front and center beautiful
day to be alive the clouds are out but
it don't matter the sun shining in that
sacrament won't keep you warm and the
people next to you nice and warm
where's that a beautiful day here I got
some [__] Larry I got some [__]
brain freeze and perennial old G you
know me I show nobodies half of a little
get the [__] out up with joy he shows up
with three guns bullets the whole
[__] thing this morning I went to
church had breakfast with the family I
put up a video made my little daughter
[__] Cocoa Krispies because we love
Cocoa Krispies you understand we don't
[__] around no more
but Joey what's with the chitter chatter
spark that [__] number
gleam NBC more is what I'm talkin about
baby
no lunch reefer come water that's I'm
livin Papillon stuck in the [__] cave
you understand we got a podcast tonight
six o'clock make sure you there make
sure you're there don't make me [__]
come get you Scott suckin but Joey spark
up another one all right all right all
right wait I'll be so [__] push you
for this time we're doing the Larry OH
this shit's been killing me inside of
rusty and [__] old
it smells like [__] my fungi toenail
that's why you know it's gonna be good
are you watching football jumping up
with your friends he limped him to
Lipton onion [__] dip with potato
chips you're gonna fear flight you're
gonna smell my [__] Michael Jackson's
body
Oh
the way we get together to smoke in the
mornings it's it's tremendously
understand you can't this is the best
show on [__] the internet right now
just a fat [__] smoking dope with you
what do you give a [__] I'm saying fat
[__] skinny [__] at least were smoking
dope having a good time that's what you
were supposed to be [__] have no does
this [__] embarrass us cuz we're family
I'm with you you're with me and that
with somebody else from him jumping up
and down make him believe you know what
the [__] crack like like I said
podcast tonight 6:00 p.m. right after
[__] dinner Friday Las Vegas
sadly Las Vegas to some point my main
man Steve DeSimone Larry will be there
my nephew arias will be there the whole
family will [__] be there then a
two-weeks [__] Boston strapped on
a pair legal seafoods put away the
[__] lobster uncle Joey's coming and
beep with [__] lee-sia
beat stars [__] I don't even know I'm
bringing so much [__] stuff that was
them we just take him a plane right to
[__] in Iran they're gonna drop us
where's the best bottom like that when I
get high with my family understand me
you look like me go enjoy really yeah I
can't you reader but I don't want to
read a book alright I show you
everything I had we briefly had the baby
this morning talking yeah never mind the
rest of these [__] maggots you
[__] why's that alrighty I give
it to you straight from the [__]
ballsack
coughs I'm a jolly enough with the
chitty-chat I'm gonna do it and that
[__] brave freezing and leave us out
here like orphans relax everything in
time you know Sam you know football
where the [__] you going you sit there
like a [__] you scored a touchdown
last week that's great talk sir go give
your wife establish she's in the other
room waiting for you and your home old
friends are watching Isaac Titan pants
run around get it together go suck a
[__] [__] till she flop it and
scores a touchdown herself in your face
under that the Mighty Clouds of Joy
that's all I have to tell you
[__] that I don't know what
you're gonna do enjoy your family cuz
they're the best thing you got Rachel
goes down do your twenty two push-ups
whatever the [__] you want to do always
keep in mind how [__] lucky we are
you know how lucky I am
are you [__] kidding me having
friends having reefer being healthy
luckiest [__] thanks buddy still
stands on finding 7-eleven I mean yeah
22:35 let the [__] you go you might
want a toaster if you're [__] lucky
the [__] luckiest day your life was a
day you got hit by a [__] by a dog
got run over by a tow truck but that's
beside the point
what I'm telling you is luck every day
will you wake up you look around even if
you got a half a soda in your
refrigerator that's most of these
[__] poor little black kids with
[__] flies on him over there in
Africa so just remember that [__]
you're lucky how lucky I am
[__] I could have still been doing time
but I'm out and I did something because
then you [__] now let's all do
something together today smoke some weed
write your goals and go out there and
stab them on the fire like Jesus when he
came out of the cave alright I'll see
you guys a 6 p.m. be there or be square
don't forget next Vegas next Friday and
Saturday only he didn't tell me we got
Steve some honorable Joey in Viva Las
Vegas then November 11 to 12 November
lemon time in Boston November 12 I'm at
the Foxwoods [__] Country Club and
Connecticut I'm going to see my [__]
people my old school folks from highway
coming up with envelopes don't forget
about me I have a [__] tremendous day
let's do one more
I'm gonna make a protein shake I'm
wanted yuge it's alright that's my
[__] day oh who loves you more than
me nobody [__] stay black I see
you till that is 6 p.m.